foreign
Americans here in Colorado were fed up
with the status quo they understand that
Michael Bennett's solely responsible for
voting for a 1.9 trillion dollar rescue
plan that caused this inflation they
know that Joe Biden and Michael Bennett
are the ones that have crushed the oil
and gas Industries Across the Nation
they know that the Democrats are the
ones that have gutted and demoralized
our police forces
what people are talking about is
inflation they're talking about price
and gas they're talking about groceries
at an all-time high and they're
especially interested in Colorado and
the hiking crime that we've seen here in
the last two years so it's made people
really feel unsecure they're worried
about their kids they're worried about
their communities
and those are the issues that are making
a big difference to working Americans
he's in favor of late term abortion on
demand
uh up into the day of birth
in Colorado they're paying four dollars
and fifty cents for gasoline so people
we need to be able to have a
conversation with them about what's
caused this the supply chain issues that
we're confronting as a result of coming
back from coven the energy prices that
we're confronting as a result of the
economy getting much better and then
Putin invading Ukraine my opponent in
this race he opposes the uh the law that
we've passed in Colorado to codify a
woman's right to choose first five
months that's between a woman and her
doctor and after that rape incest uh
life of the mother those those are
important issues that are between a
woman and a doctor
the Hispanic population
in the electorate here is 23 percent in
Colorado they're an important voice uh
they're part of my family my wife is
Hispanic her grandfather immigrated here
in Mexico back in the 50s they have the
same concerns if not on steroids about
this crime that is taking over their
neighborhoods
we've got fentanyl all-time high coming
up in here to our communities drug
trafficking
human trafficking this is a real concern
to the Hispanic community
last year we we lost 1800 coloradans to
drug overdose and so I really feel like
the the Democratic party is out of touch
on this issue
um here they're complaining about flying
some immigrants to uh Martha's Vineyard
to gain attention about an issue that's
killing our kids
we need to take the 87 000 IRS
bureaucrats that they funded through the
inflation reduction act and instead of
growing another department to shake down
working Americans we need to take that
money we need to use that money to
secure our border hire more border
agents in addition to that I would take
some of that money and I would put it
into our local police departments our
state troopers and and we need more cops
on the ground to get this crime under
control
we've got to grow our overall energy
here in Colorado and across the United
States we need to promote wind solar
nuclear geothermal good clean uh natural
gas and we need to get permitting out of
the way
I will bring solutions that help to
lower the cost of fuel lower the cost of
groceries and get this crime back under
control Michael Bennett's incapable of
that he's been there 13 years and he's
caused the problem
foreign